the great offer Hitchcock was once asked
what are the key elements of making a
memorable movie he said to make a great
film you need three things the script
the script and the script
this year's screenplays proved him right
through their creative storytelling and
inspirational theme the nominees include
a story of two brothers hi my god you
got to be kidding me
waitomo come on what is with the news my
being laid off you can't play me I'm
just presenting to piss me off
why
one of the ho
we here are the nominees for Best
Original Screenplay
[Music]
hell or high water
written by Taylor Sheridan la-la-land
written by Damien Chazelle the lobster
written by your coastland Timo and
athenaeus Filippo Manchester by the sea
written by Kenneth Lonergan twentieth
century women written by Mike Miller and
the Oscar goes to
Jenny Lonergan Manchester
[Music]
this is the first Oscar and Court
nomination for Tennant Lonnegan who's
also nominated through collecting
Manchester by the field
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much I love the movies I
love being part of the movies
thank you Matt Damon the whole thing
started with you Thank You Kimberly
Stewart Kevin Walsh Lorne back Chris
Moore Thank You Casey Affleck Casey
Affleck Casey Affleck Michelle Williams
and Lucas hedges and all the wonderful
actors in the film Amazon and roadside
and Sierra does such a beautiful job the
movies about people trying to take care
of each other in the face of terrible
adversity I have been taken care of in
my whole life by wonderful people who I
love and have loved me I wouldn't be
holding this is not for Mara Buxbaum I
wouldn't be here at all it wasn't for J
Smith Cameron Nellie Lonergan could not
love you more but I will try and the
special thanks to my stepfather Mike
Porter who's taking care of my mother
for the last five years in a way that is
an example to everyone who's ever come
across his path and farewell to my
father who passed away this year as well
thank you very very much
[Applause]